if you wanted to craft the best player
you could design it entirely around
stats he will have the most points the
most rebounds the highest efficiency and
statistically sometimes that player wins
MVP but sometimes it's just the eye test
sometimes it's just a certain look and
that can be just as valuable to a video
even if it doesn't match the retention
curve or the stats or anything like that
to sort of bring it back to YouTube it's
like I could obsess over the numbers and
sort of focus every ounce of my
attention on maximizing the numbers on
paper and theoretically that means it's
a good video because people made it to
the end and I successfully maximized
retention that's not my only focus and I
think if it is my only focus I might
lose a little bit of the rest of what
makes a good video